et puis dans quelques instants ce sera
la chronique de l'éco également alice
gastines va me rejoindre avec ses
invités mais politique je vous le disais
les élections municipales de 2014
c'est dans un peu près un an et demi
mais déjà on s'affaire dans de
nombreuses communes notamment la plaisir
le maire va passer à la main ump dès ce
soir lors d'un conseil municipal
exceptionnel
ils étaient en plateau il ya quelques
jours pour ceux qui ont manqué son
intervention voici un rappel de la
situation avec catherine mulato joël
regnault vit ses dernières heures comme
maire de plaisir ce jeudi soir conseil
municipal extraordinaire
les 39 conseillers municipaux plaisir wa
vont se réunir pour élire un nouveau
maire
eh bien j'ai souhaité tout simplement
comme dans une entreprise anticipées ce
passage de relais
c'est important parce que on ne peut
plus prendre de risques avec les
collectivités
je vais rester au conseil municipal pour
les apps pour les aider et les
accompagner tant que faire se peut
jusqu'en mars 2014 préparé avec la
campagne électorale je ne serai pas sur
la liste de mars 2014
joël regnault passe la main à son
adjointe à la culture joséphine coleman
berger élu à la ville de plaisir depuis
2001 elle est investie depuis 30 ans
dans le milieu associatif et artistique
du côté de l'opposition le départ de
joël regnault s'explique pour eux la
campagne des municipales est lancée
aujourd'hui
pour nombre de plaisir oit le compte n'y
est pas et que donc les habitants
attendent quelque chose de plus je pense
que la majorité en a déjà conscience et
donc d'une certaine façon moi je pars du
principe qu aujourd'hui 18 mois avant
mars 2014 eh bien on est rentré en
campagne municipale je me dis que somme
toute c'est assez assez logique
mêmes causes mêmes marges et donc son
ajointe à la culture qui va lui succéder
je trouve a été beaucoup mis en avant
depuis un peu plus d'un an
ça s'est vu nous donne faim notamment de
la compagnie sur les sénatoriales elle
était 6e sur la liste de gérard larcher
une passation de pouvoir entre un maire
et un adjoint cela n'est pas rare
récemment le cas s'est présenté à la
verrière et à magny les hameaux où
respectivement pierre celle en cours et
jacno lloze ont quitté leur fauteuil de
maire avant la fin de leur mandat
de retour sur le plateau du 7-8 ans ce
15 novembre en direct entre 18h et 19h
alice bonsoir on va parler économie avec
vous dans quelques minutes avec vos
invités florent dupuis de l'association
ighrem et puis guy malandain maire de
trappes bonsoir à tous les deux d'abord
guy malandain puisque vous êtes en
plateau on va en profiter pour parler
juste un petit peu politique avec vous
on vient de voir un reportage concernant
joël regnault le maire de plaisir qui
passe la main mary ump de plaisir à la
verrière la situation s'est produite
également à magny les hameaux
est ce que dans votre cas vous pensez
aussi passer la main en cours de mandat
je resterai jusqu'au bout de votre
mandat mais oui je suis élu pour
accomplir ce mandat pour l'instant je
fais de mon mieux d une part et d'autre
part je vais bien ça me passionne
voilà chaque matin je suis au boulot
jusqu'à tard le soir pour eux le service
des habitants et je crois qu'on je les
apprécie tellement que j'ai pas du tout
envie de partir à face à un candidat en
mars 2014
sans doute que oui sans doute car une
très bien en tête de liste si je suis
candidat ce sera on est parti je ne dis
pas ça de manière prétentieux je dis
simplement dans le cadre de la fonction
que j'exerce depuis 2001 depuis 2001
effectivement vous êtes le maire le
maire donne trappe
je vous pose tout de même cette question
pour être bien clair puisqu'il a été
aussi question de benoît hamon pendant
un temps c'est vous qui l'avez fait
venir un petit peu sur cette
circonscription son genou est lui en
tant que député est ce que vous pensez à
un moment le le fait revenir aussi sur
la municipalité ça ne s'organise pas de
cette manière moi j'ai demandé à benoît
devenir pour la députation il vous ne
pensiez pas mais l'instabilité venu il
était venu d'abord pour
pas une des des régionales jeunes à
chercher un endroit c'est c'est un ami d
steam d'amitié et ses terroristes a donc
la place était disponible
c'est bien qu'il soit venu il saura
s'ils le souhaitent dans dans l'équipe
municipale
tant qu'il est ministre il ne peut pas
être dans l'équipe municipale
si on met en application les les
théories de lionel jospin por ktm a mis
en musique samedi si pâle il pourra
encore moins et adjoint au maire on n'en
est pas là je lui souhaite bon courage
pour remplir avec talent et conviction
comme il en est capable
la fonction qui lui a été confiée dont
nous parlerons je crois tout à l'heure
effectivement on va reparler très
rapidement et donc vous serez candidat
vraisemblablement en mars 2014 on nous
l'avait dirigé en vost et où ce genre
n'existe physique tout de même pas notre
sujet je voulais aborder avec vous très
brièvement et on va glisser vers
l'économie justement progressivement
c'est la bataille menée par le maire
écologiste de sevran sa commune fait
partie des plus défavorisés comme comme
celle de trappes
il vient d'obtenir après une semaine de
grève de la faim des subventions
supplémentaires pour lui nous aussi pour
les ailes toutes ces communes en
difficulté quel regard vous avez sur ce
combat qu'il a mené
juan tout le monde peut discuter de la
méthode sevran une ville difficile mais
il n'ya pas que sevran comme ville
difficile donc nous n'avons pas procéder
de cette manière là nous avons fait un
travail
avec un certain nombre de députés un
certain nombre de sénateurs travaillent
qui d'ailleurs est publié dans le
journal municipal de ce mois ci qui est
sorti cet après midi qui consiste à
travailler sur une répartition plus
équitable des dotations de l'état dont
on sait très bien dans le climat
économique actuel elles sont forcément
forcément limitée et avant-hier soir
l'amendement que nous avions proposé a
été votée à l'assemblée il
il répare il réparer une injustice qui
avait été fait dans la loi de finances
donc je vous qu'avez-vous finalement ces
nuages invités vous avez vous finalement
obtenu que les choses se fassent
oui mais voilà pour les nous avions la
ligue obtenue que les 150 premières
communes les plus pauvres
si je puis dire et nous nous sommes
cinquante et unième attrape soient
exonérés de leur contribution au fonds
de solidarité de la région ile-de-france
comme ils sont exonérés comme elles sont
exonérées au du de leur participation au
fonds de péréquation communales et
intercommunales
ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas
considérer que on est parmi les plus
pauvres malheureusement cela correspond
à des situations objectives pas des
idées comme ça en l'air après avoir
saigné également verser une contribution
des communes qui vont très bien et tant
mieux
et c'est bien qu'ils aient des communes
qu'il n'est pas besoin de cette
solidarité mais mais on va pas renverser
les choses je peux pas limité comme
s'était fait dans dans la dernière loi
de finances de l'ex majorité je veux pas
limiter la contribution solidarité de
levallois-perret andouillé janvier puis
demander à attrape sevran
à chanteloup à mantes-la-jolie de
contribuer sont je crois que c'était pas
sérieux donc c'est rectifier les c'est
bien guy malandain vous restez avec nous
et l'heure de la chronique échos
l'économie sociale et solidaire à
l'honneur